well you were all busy watching Marjorie
Taylor green show off Hunter Biden's
homemade porn don't worry we'll get to
it something more significant was
happening on Capitol Hill IRS
whistleblowers were blowing the lid on
Biden family corruption and the most
damning clip did not even come from
Republicans grilling the tax agents in a
Committee hearing the most damning
testimony came from a whistleblower
speaking to a liberal journalist on CBS
News
did you uncover evidence that President
Biden financially benefited from his
son's deals I don't feel comfortable
answering that question why is that any
time we potentially wanted to go down
the road of asking questions related to
the president it was that's going to
take too much approvals we can't ask
those questions and I mean it created it
created an environment that was very
hard to deal with it's a politically
sensitive case wouldn't it require
additional approvals yes I do understand
that that aspect but it would be like
well let's think about it let's put that
on the back burner
now the story here is not that Joe Biden
benefited from Hunter Biden's corrupt
business dealings everybody already knew
that we've seen the receipts we've read
the emails we've seen the texts 10 for
the big guy
everyone knows and has known for a long
time that the big guy is on the take and
selling American influence to the
highest bidders including our enemies
the story here
is that CBS aired this interview the
story here
is that the liberal establishment has
soured on Joe Biden and is prepared
should the opportunity present itself to
push him out of the race I'm Michael
Knowles it's the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show we as I
mentioned we will get to the weird
Marjorie Taylor green Hunter Biden porn
in the Congressional committee we have
to get to it don't worry we've blurted
more even than uh Congressman Greene did
but first speaking of presidents and our
adversaries president Trump
is in big big trouble among the libs and
among his opponents on the right because
president Trump here he goes again
putting his foot in his mouth he praised
Chinese leader Xi Jinping
I love you too I will tell you that but
think of President XI Central Casting
brilliant guy you know when I say he's
brilliant everyone says oh that's
terrible you call it well he runs 1.4
billion people with an iron fist smart
brilliant everything perfect there's
nobody in Hollywood like this guy I got
them to pay us 28 billion dollars
because they screwed our Farmers for
years and I had the secretary of
agriculture come up and I said give me a
number they said it's 28 billion dollars
comes back a week later it's 28 billion
dollars I said that's a lot I said well
we're going to take it from China I got
28 billion dollars for the farmers who
got a check
and
headline Trump Praises Xi Jinping
there's two layers to this story it's a
very ingenuous headline
but the first layer is
when Trump says oh she is brilliant
which he obviously is he's a very
successful popular leader of a gigantic
country that's developed rapidly and
that is now challenging American
hegemony obviously he's a pretty
talented leader but when he says that
when Trump says oh he's big and smart
and talented and skilled
why is he saying that because then the
very next sentence is and I beat him
he's he's praising his opponent in the
way that a guy who gets in a street
fight brags about how big the other guy
was oh this guy he was walking around
he's the biggest it was Goliath walking
down the street and then me I went in
there and boom sucked it to him that's
right he's really big and the fact that
I beat him means that I'm even bigger
and I'm even more talented and I'm even
more brilliant so that's obviously what
he's doing here he's not expressing his
political philosophy and his deep
knowledge of Chinese history or anything
like that he's just bragging about what
a good job he did when he was
negotiating with G okay now there's
another layer to this which is at a
deeper level
there is a strain of American
conservatism that while it doesn't like
Xi Jinping necessarily it doesn't love
Xi Jinping it has a grudging kind of
admiration and respect for Xi Jinping
and I know that this is going to seem
totally insane to the libertarian-minded
people on the right but the the reason
that one might have a kind of grudging
admiration or respect for Xi Jinping
even in the west is because Xi Jinping
commands Authority he runs his nation in
a an orderly way and he governs
According to some conception albeit a
mistaken conception of the common good
that's why
please don't shoot the messenger I'm
just explaining to you that there is a
strain on the right
that is represented in the intellectual
circles on the right it's represented in
the rank and file and the Grassroots on
the right that admires strong leaders
who can run their countries according to
their own
Traditions according to their own
political Vision according to their own
conception of the common good and can
resist the Imperial liberalism that is
has been attempted to be voiced on for a
long time
you see this especially in certain
post-liberal circles in common good
conservatives there's a really good
interview with uh Harvard law professor
Adrian vermeul in the Beijing review
explaining some of the reasons for which
an American conservative might look to
China and not merely criticize
everything but try to learn some things
as well if you read some speeches of Xi
Jinping
some of what he says would fit in
perfectly well at an American
conservative conference and so it's true
that the libs some of the the far left
they like Xi Jinping because he's at
least nominally a communist practically
speaking he's not even really a
communist yes and he doesn't go on and
on about marks and angles and Lenin and
Stalin but that's why the the hard left
might like Xi Jinping but the reason why
some conservatives might somewhat admire
Xi Jinping is because the reasons I
mentioned because
He commands Authority because he's not
liberal and because he's governing
according to a deeper tradition
conservatives
especially of the traditional variety
respect
the right of cultures to practice their
own Traditions within reason not in a
way that is totally relativistic and
says well if you want to go off into
your crazy evil murder land you know
that's your right because you know in in
your region you're allowed to rule As
You Wish no we believe in certain
Eternal principles and eternal truths
but we have far greater respect for
traditions and culture than the liberals
do the liberals who want to homogenize
everything and and govern according to
whatever the the ideological fashion is
in
2023 that's why I don't know that Trump
was getting at that deeper philosophy he
might have just been bragging but Trump
being a representative of the populist
right and being a voice winning or
unwilling for a more traditional
classical conception of conservatism and
politics I wouldn't be surprised if just
in his gut he recognizes oh it's good to
have an orderly Society a lot of what
China is doing is really bad we would
not want to do that here in the west we
don't really have much of a tradition of
doing that here in the west but it is
good for the law and for the government
to command Authority and govern in a way
that is consistent with a national
tradition that's why don't shoot the
messenger but that's a real strain and
by the way that's the strain that's
gaining on the right far more so than
the
quasi-libertarianism of the past 30
years which says oh do whatever you want
as long as it doesn't affect me and I
don't need to pay more taxes for it yeah
you can chop people up and you can go do
whatever weird stuff you want in the
street and you can
redefine all of education and culture
just just don't make me pay for it that
very shallow view of politics that's on
its way out and the deeper more
classical traditional View
that's on the way up and when that does
finally emerge as the dominant force in
politics you're going to want to look
good for it okay and when you want to
look good you got to check out gen
yourself right now head on over to
geniusell.com Knowles our friends are
Virginia cell sold out of their Dark
Spot Corrector and our listeners have
been begging begging like dogs for a
restock well I've got great news just in
time for summer it's back in stock genu
sells famous Dark Spot Corrector has not
won but three Cutting Edge ingredients
goes to work fast to Target sunspots
dark spots liver spots even old
discoloration both on your face and
hands you can now enjoy your summer sun
Beach barbecues without any embarrassing
spots geniuselle's most popular package
also features their summer Essentials
such as their best-selling Ultra retinol
moisturizer with a powerful retinol
alternative for safe use in the sun you
will be amazed at how quickly you see
the results or you get 100 of your money
back guaranteed I love this company I
love the owner great Coptic Christian
from Egypt who left Egypt for the
America Can Dream head on over to
genucel.com Knowles right now get your
dark spot corrector in the genius all
most popular package geniusell.com
Knowles save over 70 7-0 off geniusl's
most popular package all orders will
include a mystery luxury gift ooh well
supplies last geniusell.com Knowles
speaking of conservative messages for
the Trump campaign Steve Bannon showed
up a few days ago at the Turning Point
action conference and Bannon
went pretty far in the theme
for the Trump campaign
this is a crusade
this is a holy war against the Deep
state
Donald Trump is our instrument for
Retribution
I don't want to hear Glenn yonkin in
advance I don't want to hear camp with
his George acts I don't want to hear it
Donald Trump is our instrument for
righteous ignignation
but Steve what do you really think I
just wish he wouldn't be so reticent you
know he's such a Wallflower what do you
think it's a holly War it's a crusade
what's going on
Bannon was the top strategist to Trump
for at least part of the 2016 race he
worked in the white house for Trump he
left the White House he sort of booted
out but then he came back into Trump's
orbit so what exactly is going on here
is this the Trump Campaign theme is this
just Steve Bannon going off is what this
is
the Trump campaign testing campaign
messages and campaign themes without it
coming out of Trump's mouth
that's where we are right now we are so
early on I know a lot of people want to
say the primary is over the election is
over just move on it's all done we are
so far away not only from the general
election but even from the Iowa caucuses
this is still Silly Season in politics
and so you're going to see Trump and
DeSantis and Vivek ramaswami and other
guys just throw spaghetti at the wall
and one safe way to do it as I've
pointed out before this primary is is
defined I think by everyone playing it
safe right now Trump's not showing up to
a candidate Forum with Tucker Carlson
Ron DeSantis is is playing his his role
as Trump 2.0 he's not veering too far
off that script which has proven to work
in the past the only candidate who is
really getting a little bit eccentric
and creative is Vivek ramaswami and he's
he's the only one being rewarded for it
too because his poll numbers are
increasing pretty dramatically everyone
is playing it safe all the other
candidates who are in the single digits
right now they're just playing it safe
so the safe way to test out campaign
themes is to do so through surrogates
like Steve Bannon we'll see if that one
plays it might be a little bit much for
uh the voters in Pennsylvania and New
Hampshire but maybe not it depends how
fervent the populist appetite of the
country is right now the libs for one do
not like this kind of talk about Holy
Wars and and Crusades and cultural Wars
uh Tommy tuberville the Republican
senator has been holding up some defense
Appropriations and and
promotions of people in the dod because
the dod has gone super woke and the
Pentagon is spending its time not
fighting terrorists but worried about
white rage and every other woke
fashionable ideology so tell real saying
hey we got to get this nonsense out of
the military or I'm not going to give
you your promotions David Brooks the
kind of conservative by liberal
standards but kind of just Center lib
columnist he took tuberville to task and
he said military is no place for a
culture War
this was a bipartisan Enterprise what do
you make of this effort by Republicans
to use this bill as a cudgel in the
culture wars and to really virtue signal
to members of their base yeah I mean
there are two things going on here one
is the Amendments which I'm basically
fine with like having the Pentagon pay
for people to travel for abortion that's
a policy Choice depending animated
policy Choice it's based on a set of
philosophies and there are some other
Republicans have a different philosophy
and so they can try to vote it down and
that's fine that's to me that's the
Democratic process the terrible thing
that's happening is Senator tuberville
is blocking promotions until he gets his
abortion policy correct and that just
weakens the military it's fine to have a
debate it's fine to have amendments it's
fine to have a policy process it's not
fine to weaken a our military because of
your philosophy
did you did you follow that I had a
little trouble following that he started
out fine he said look the the libs who
are running the dod they want to fund
abortion all over the place and if a
state passes a law to protect unborn
babies it's it's fine for the military
to spend your taxpayer dollars to
circumvent those duly passed laws by
paying to murder babies in other states
that's that's look that's their
philosophy and look Tommy toberville and
the Republicans they have their other
philosophy and they want to fight that
out they want to Duke it out that's fine
but what's really awful
is that the Republicans are actually
fighting
look it's fine to have a debate this is
what David Brooks is saying it's fine to
have a debate
as long as the Republicans lose
it's okay look the Republicans don't
want to murder babies the Liberals at
the Pentagon they fanatically want to
murder babies and so it's fine to go to
the Congress and you can have your
debate on the C-SPAN cameras that's the
Democratic process but the conservatives
actually winning and actually fighting
that's not the Democratic process that's
very very undemocratic and very very bad
what democracy means is that we have a
facade of a debate we have a pretend
debate that the conservatives always
lose
and the that the conservatives always
fight without any actual strength or
Prospect of winning
David Brooks
was once considered the conservative at
the New York Times
in in some quarters David Brooks is
still considered kind of a conservative
which makes perfect sense doesn't it
because David Brooks's role was to go to
the New York Times and be the kind of
pretend conservative but then give up
all the conservative priorities
and gracefully lose or concede those
priorities so that the libs always win
so that you have the appearance of a
debate so that you have the appearance
of democracy but you don't have to deal
with the actual consequences of that
this is what the libs do all the time
this is why when the voters of Hungary
go out and they overwhelmingly elect a
conservative government that's a threat
to democracy
this is why when the voters of Italy go
out and they overwhelmingly elect a
woman who campaigned as a conservative
she hasn't really government as a
conservative but she campaigned as an
Ardent conservative and then she wins
that's a threat to democracy same thing
with the brexit same thing with the
elections in Sweden same things with the
elections and Trump
we're we the conservatives are supposed
to just not only lose graciously but
basically concede we're not even really
supposed to fight
okay and a lot of conservatives in the
last five six seven years around this
time that you've seen the rise of the
populist movements and Trump and brexit
and Maloney and urban and Sweden and
movements all around the West
that we've been told that's the greatest
threat ever and and this is why you're
seeing the bureaucracy in Brussels and
in Washington D.C come in to try to
undermine those victories because For
the first time in a very very long time
the conservatives are actually fighting
and actually winning now speaking of the
culture War
Jason Aldean
is canceled
I don't follow a lot of popular music
I've heard Jason Aldean is a great guy
we have some mutual friends
had never listened to his music actively
I don't listen to really any pop music
actively and Jason Aldean had this song
all I heard about it was this song is
racist and controversial and awful and
terrible and so it's been pulled from
Country Music Television so I said okay
I guess I got to listen to this song
somebody on a sidewalk carjacking old
lady at a red light pull a gun on the
owner of a liquor store you think it's
cool like the fool if you like
spit in this face
[Music]
you don't
try that in a small town
[Applause]
okay goes on
but you basically get the gist there's
the verse there's the chorus
and this is deeply terribly awfully
offensive
according to here's a writer for a raw
story liberal Outlet Mark Chapman I'm
sorry Matthew Chapman says I'll say this
much this song absolutely captures
everything about the American right from
the paranoid threats of violence to the
irrational fetishization of communities
where everyone acts and thinks the same
to the fact that the singer in fact grew
up in a city I guess he grew up in a
slightly larger town okay the guy's a
popular Entertainer all right I think
you can have a little artistic license
the paranoid
threats of violence
paranoid
meaning we think there are threats where
there are none after
BLM burned down the country for eight
months after I'll just speak from my own
experience after antifa tried to blow me
up in Pittsburgh like two months ago and
the FBI finally arrested them and the
doj has charged them after increasing
violence in all of our cities
and specifically increasing violence
against conservatives the irrational
fetishization of communities where
everyone thinks and acts the same first
of all
who who do you think is a bigger
promoter of homogeneity right now in
culture the left or the right
who's the one pushing that that same
rainbow flag on every Community around
the country who's the one insisting on
the exact same standards and norms and
behaviors for everyone around the
country a blanket kind of censorship for
anyone who differs from the prevailing
Orthodoxy of the day is it the left or
the right it's obviously the left that's
pushing all of that
but people are are getting wrong I think
why Jason Aldean was was censored people
think it's because he talks about
you know had a fight off the people's
sucker punching people on a sidewalk and
the carjackers and the liquor store
robbers that is not
why we'll get to why in a second first
though speaking of guns
when you want to just shoot your meat
full of fire you got to check out Grill
Blazer right now go to grillblazer.com
use promo code Knolls Grill Blazers
Grill guns are designed to do everything
from lighting my cigars to lighting my
other cigars you could also use them to
expertly sear your meat Light charcoal
grills wood stoves after fireplaces just
about anything you can think of for
which you would need high power Fire
Grill Blazers offers two types of Grill
guns the grill gun basic is a high power
propane torch designed to Light charcoal
and wood grills and smokers burns up to
3 600 Degrees which is the average
temperature of Phoenix Arizona in the
month of July its 30 inch flame is for
anything that you need a big bad torch
to do and then there's the cute little
sous-vide gun it's got a little bit of a
shorter Barrel perfect for professional
Culinary Kitchen uses from gently
carbonizing or other sugars and fruits
to rapidly searing steaks outside on the
grill using the grill gun may result in
extreme Grill Envy from your neighbors
so user discretion advised get your
grill gun from Grill Blazers today let
the grilling Adventures begin
rollblazer.com use promo code nulls for
15 off your order grillblazer.com
for 15 off your order
folks I've got some fantastic news for
you have you ever wondered what it would
have been like to take a stroll through
the capitol on January 6th the worst day
in the history of
history maybe what it's like to take a
walk on the surface of the Sun
well
you're in luck because my guest on
Michael and has first-hand experience
with at least one of those things and
claims firsthand experience with both of
them don't miss the first sit-down
long-form interview with Jacob chansley
the Q Anon Shaman since he was released
from jail
they call him the Q Anon Shaman they
call him the horn hat guy he's the man
from January 6th check out this teaser
you were in solitary confinement for ten
and a half months ten and a half months
that seems like torture and I
experienced some miraculous things in
solitary I'm freaking out I'm in a Cell
I'm freaking out I'm like what the hell
and I had a Bible in my hand I said I
need you to speak with me so I closed my
eyes I opened the Bible I point to a
random verse and the verse was I am
yours and you are mine I have redeemed
you and called you by name oh Jacob
oh yeah
[Music]
what is a shaman what is a woman what
really happened on January 6th find out
in this trippy dippy interview which is
out now the big Tech approved version of
this two and a half hour interview is on
YouTube But be sure to catch the full
interview the uncensored version that is
only available on Twitter at M Knolls
show and daily wire plus there you can
watch the whole thing some of the big
Tech oligarchs don't want us
to show you
now speaking of censorship Jason Aldean
is censored for this song try that in a
small town people think as they call it
racist and
I don't know sexist probably and
paranoid and right-wing and all the rest
they think that he's talking about the
lyrics sucker punch somebody on a
sidewalk carjack an old lady at a red
light pull a gun on the owner of a
liquor store
that's not what he's talking about it's
pretty amazing that the libs are now
openly defending sucker punching
somebody on the sidewalk but that's not
that's not what he irritated them what
irritated them is that last
two words
small town
what they what they don't like is that
he's defending small towns
because when you defend small towns what
you're defending is
federalism subsidiarity the idea that
different communities are going to have
different Traditions from you
in within your own nation and among all
of the Nations when we can respect
people
's right to engage in certain cultural
traditions and not seek to impose all of
our culture every single aspect of our
culture everywhere else in the world
subsidiarity very conservative very
Christian principle
also because it's those those small
towns that are are the impediments to
the libs just taking over and
controlling everything and what's the
smallest unit of the small town it's the
family so the libs constantly try to
destroy the family ultimately the libs
try to destroy a local Rule and
subsidiarity after that then the libs
take away state rights and then then the
libs even try to give away National
sovereignty so that we're just living in
some big liberal Global blob that's the
problem
has nothing to do with racism or
violence or anything like that the libs
hate the deepest theme of the song
the small town
speaking of Libs wanting to make their
cultural radicalism a matter of national
and even International policy we have to
turn to assistant Health secretary
[Music]
speaking of weird sex stuff I said I
would get to it I guess we will
Marjorie green Republican congressman
just featured quite an obscene and
pornographic display in a house
Committee hearing
she was referring to the evidence that
was found on Hunter Biden's laptop which
showed that he paid a hooker out of his
law firm's bank account and she featured
semi-blocked out
semi-censored images of Hunter engaging
in weird sex acts with said hookers we
here at the daily wire at the Michael
Mills show have blurted out even further
this is a family program here is what
Congress lady Greene had to say
I will let the screen wrap up
five seconds and then I'll give Mr
mafume additional time thank you Mr
chairman
um Mr shapley you you saw an
investigation under Hunter Biden
codename Sportsman which opened in
November of 2018.
um it was an offshoot of an
investigation the IRS was conducting
into a foreign-based amateur online
pornography platform
um this this is evidence
of Hunter Biden
excuse me this is my time making
pornography should we be displaying this
Mr chairman did the community
should we be displaying this Mr chairman
this is obscene
this is pornographic you hear the
Democrat off camera yelling and
screaming and crying because Marjorie
green is showing censored pictures of
Hunter Biden engaging in an oral sex act
okay
fair enough liberals in the media
started whining immediately after the
Congress lady did this and I agree I
totally agree with the criticism it's
obscene it's pornographic
it has no place in the House of
Representatives
but unfortunately today those same
people who are raising all of those
objections
they're insisting that more graphic
displays of even more obscene and
depraved sexual acts belong in
Elementary School classrooms
because all those very same people who
are clutching their pearls how dare you
Congress lady green how dare you show a
censored picture of Hunter Biden
engaging in some sex acts those recent
people are permitting genderqueer the
book by Maya kababi in Elementary School
classrooms and when conservatives like
Ron DeSantis go in and they say no we're
going to ban that book from Elementary
School classrooms because it's depraved
gay porn showing more depraved versions
of the same sex act that Marjorie green
showed censored as Representatives they
say that belongs in kindergarten
that belongs in your Elementary School
library so can the Democrats please
explain to me
why this kind of pornography has no
place in the House of Representatives to
be viewed by adults as a as a matter of
debating National policy and National
political Scandal but it does belong in
the classroom of five-year-olds
in an even more obscene way why is that
something tells me they're being a
little disingenuous about their
opposition to pornography and obscenity
and the Pearl clutching
look man I'm all for it we have
obscenity laws on the books I think we
should enforce them we have a long
tradition in America of banning
pornographic and obscene materials I
think pornography is one of if not the
biggest
basically not spoken of social problems
in the country because it's ubiquitous
and it puts people in a state of
Perpetual mortal sin and it puts a huge
percentage of the population in that
state and it's very difficult it's
actually impossible to have a good
Republic
when you've got people constantly
engaging in Vice that's degrading so I'm
off let's do it baby
let's ban this stuff from certainly from
the Congress let's ban it from all sorts
of places
but you want to put it into elementary
schools so what the left tells me then
is it loves the obscenity it loves the
depravity it loves the pornography it
wants to present all of this stuff to
the most innocent people in our country
it just doesn't want to get caught
in the act of the consequences of that
depravity
the the country that presents porn
everywhere is the country that becomes a
nation of Hunter bidens that actually
does this stuff but they want to cover
up the consequences they want all of the
titillation they want all of the
degradation they just don't want to get
caught in their own depravity and
Corruption of course now speaking of
students really shocking footage just
came out of Canada America's Top Hat
Canada has a teacher in Windsor Ontario
an elementary school teacher caught on
tape berating Muslim Students for having
committed this the sin of skipping LGBT
elementop Pride day
you need to understand
how hurt
[Music]
in those actions
and take that home to your parents
because they're the ones who made you
stay home
it was an incredible
show
of hatred
and it is sad
it was hatred
[Music]
the community of people
and it was
incredibly
disgusting to have witnessed
do not want to be a part of this school
this woman this woman is yelling at kids
who are 10 years old at the oldest
she might be yelling at five-year-olds
we don't it's only audio so we don't
know which age of Elementary student
she's yelling at she's yelling at
Muslims for being Muslim
she's yelling and she's not singling out
Muslims she she is in the sense that
they are the students who didn't want to
show up to the pride day
but a Christian Student practicing his
faith wouldn't want to show up to the
pride day a Jewish student practicing
his faith wouldn't want to show an
orthodox Jew wouldn't want to show up to
the pride day
a traditional just kind of normal
agnostic wouldn't want to show up to the
pride day and she's saying hey you you
discussed it you're it's disgusting if
you believe in God and the Bible at all
if you believe in traditional morality
in any way you're disgusting 10 year
olds
I'm just I don't want to be part of this
school anymore
the lesson here is not just that the
libs are preying on little kids and they
hate Christianity and and even the
associated abrahamic religions
the other lesson is that politics makes
strange bedfellows which we'll get to in
a second first though despite the
lackluster economy the daily wire is
thriving and not only that we're hiring
we are currently looking for a graphic
designer to join our fast growing
creative Department as a graphic
designer you will collaborate with
copywriters creative directors and other
designers under the guidance the
executive creative director to craft
show assets and thumbnails for a variety
of media to excel in this role you will
need Proficiency in Adobe Creative Cloud
experience creating engaging web
Graphics key and attention to detail and
excellent communication and
collaboration skills the position is
based in Nashville Tennessee if you are
interested in joining our team go to
dailywire.com careers that is
dailywire.com careers today
my favorite comment yesterday is from
doctor calibrations 79.84
who says quoting me once Trump is dead
they'll dig him up and indict him
rare Michael Knowles L the libs would
not indict a brand new liberal voter
great Point you're you're so true about
that they will indict Donald Trump every
remaining day of his life until
eventually he dies but then they will
start to really like him once he dies
because that will be when he registers
as a Democrat great point you make a
great point
back to the lib teacher screaming at the
Muslim Students in Canada
an important lesson it gets back to what
we're talking about at the top of the
show
politics makes strange bedfellows
so
in this case we spent
15 years
of my life from about 2000 2001 to 2015
call it's 14 years
the conservatives in America were
broadly opposed to Islam because we were
fighting a war on terror because of the
9 11 Terror attacks because we
believed in the idea that there was a
clash of civilizations between
Christianity and Islam with some good
reason let's not forget Islam has been
attempting to invade the West with more
and less success since about the 7th
Century let's not forget that the Battle
of Poitier was fought 150 miles outside
of Paris not Mecca in the early 8th
Century let's not forget the Battle of
Lepanto another attempted Muslim
invasion of the West let's not forget
the Battle of Vienna another attempted
Muslim invasion of the West so
there is precedent for them I'm not
saying that the conservatives were
totally crazy but now in the year of Our
Lord 2023 do you think is a conservative
that the biggest threat to your
civilization comes from Islam
I certainly don't think that in America
in fact in many ways I think I have
common cause with Muslims who despite
our theological and cultural differences
oppose the radical sexual ideologies
coming out of the left as you heard on
that tape from Canada
as you see at a community board meeting
in Michigan when it's the Muslim board
that's saying no to the radical sexual
ideological agenda of the left now we've
got common cause
you're seeing a similar similar thing
play out here when Trump Praises someone
like Xi Jinping does that mean that we
love Xi Jinping we love the Chinese
Communists or the Chinese
pseudo-communists the party that used to
be much more communistic but is now I
don't know what it is it's just
totalitarian broadly no it doesn't mean
that we
are are in in line now with the Chinese
Communists or anything like that but it
does mean that politics make strange
bedfellas and when you see a ruler in
China saying no also to that very same
radical leftist sexual agenda
we say oh there's some common cause
there when you see a leader in China
who's at least speaking of the common
good who's at least speaking in a way
that is vaguely reminiscent of the
classical political tradition in the
west that crucially opposes liberalism
then conservatives can recognize that in
the very least in that narrow case we've
got some kind of common cause there
politics makes for strange bedfellows
and the the people who are politically
shallow will get very angry about this
they'll pull their hair out
they'll say hold on ten years ago you
opposed this person or this idea or this
group of people but now you're making
common cause with that thing against
this other thing that you now perceive
to be a greater more urgent threat
but people who have been around politics
for a while who've thought about
politics for a while will say yeah
that's politics man
politics is the application of Eternal
truths to changing circumstances
politics is a Practical Art and Science
that involves real people
and real geography
and real economies
and real cultures and real stuff in
history in time and space which changes
it's not frozen it's not frozen in Amber
now all of a sudden you look at those
Muslims up in Canada you say hey fellas
you're a lot closer to the right track
than the crazy leftists that are
destroying America's Top Hat speaking of
Muslims and foreign policy Travis Scott
has just had his concert canceled in
Egypt who is Travis Scott I don't really
remember I only remember him as being
this kind of eccentric popular musician
who performs bizarre occult rituals and
uses satanic and occult imagery in his
public performances overt image rate
this is not a satanic Panic looking for
Devils under every Rock and this is very
overt the stage for one of his concerts
was was a depiction of hieronymous
Bosch's you know uh hellish
images and he regularly uses this kind
of satanic language and and imagery so
anyway he was supposed to perform a
concert at the Giza Pyramid
and Egypt just said no
Egyptian authorities said no thank you
we don't want your weird occult satanic
stuff uh
since the general Syndicate is part of
the fabric of this Beloved Country it is
Keen on its stability and security and
refuses to tamper with societal values
and Egyptian and Arab customs and
traditions based on research and
documented information about strange
rituals at Travis's concerts that are
inconsistent with our authentic societal
values and traditions the board of
directors has decided to cancel the
license issued to hold this type of
concert that contradicts the cultural
identity of the Egyptian people very
based very good wonderful stuff and we
should
we should seek to emulate that sort of
thing in the West
similar to Trump saying a nice thing
about Xi Jinping does it mean now that
we want to model our country after Egypt
and the Muslim leaders of Egypt no it
doesn't but they're right about this
issue
just like Xi Jinping can be right about
a thing or two also
and in political humility we can look
toward other cultures and try to take
the best of what they're doing and try
to learn from them
and in the West in recent years the
occult imagery that is cropped up is so
bizarre and so over at Sam Smith dancing
around as a devil
all of this kind of imagery
it's much more prominent in the west
than it used to be and we we seem to
have lost the ability to say no to it
now we have Baphomet statues inside
public spaces inside government
buildings well in the name of religious
liberty now we have satanic clubs in
elementary schools we've reported on it
on this show before
openly overtly and why is this happening
because we in the liberal West have lost
the ability to say no and other nations
that many of the Liberals would deride
as authoritarian ironic because the
Liberals are much more authoritarian
than anybody else in the country
certainly more so than the conservatives
some of those other nations that have a
deeper political tradition and that look
a little deeper than consent as the
be-all and end all moral Criterion for
public policy and who recognize that
there are other things and other virtues
to take into account as well in policy
they just look at that and they say oh
no you got the satanic singer and he
wants to sing by the pyramid yet no
thanks that's not in line with our
values in Egypt
conservatives I think need to learn that
lesson we need to be able to say no
thanks religious liberty doesn't give
religious liberty certainly not as the
founders and framers understood it
doesn't give you any right to have a
Baphomet doll in a public space doesn't
give you a right to practice Satanism
doesn't give you a righteous satanic
Club in an elementary school doesn't
give you a right to perform all sorts of
other sick bizarre rituals that are
sometimes overtly occult and sometimes
or merely uh implicitly so in the weird
ideologies that the libs are forcing
everywhere especially in the month of
June
we should just say no to that and we
need to we need to figure out well on
what what grounds can we say now
liberalism
exalts
consent and individual autonomy Above
All Else and the consequence of that is
it erodes the cultural Foundation that
allowed it to operate in the first place
well what are we going to replace that
with as we think a little bit more
deeply about what it means to be a
conservative what it means to be an
American what it means to live in the
west which used to be known as
Christendom
this is theology Thursday baby and we
have a special guest here all the way
over from the Tim pool media Empire
we have Mary Morgan coming on the show
the rest of the show continues now you
do not want to miss it become a member
use code Knowles Canada wlas a check out
for two months free on all annual plans
[Music]